oh god will this succeed
i think i might be on my way to making
crystal pepsi tonight ah
crystal pepsi the blast from the past
that just won't leave the public
conscience
or at least it won't leave mine it was
first produced for a few years in the
early 90s which is also when i was first
produced and it's had a few limited runs
since
most notably one in 2016. but now in
2020
in spite of massive public demand
crystal pepsi is nowhere to be found
which leaves me with
no choice but to make it myself
[Music]
so the way i see it there are two major
methods i can go about trying to make
crystal pepsi and i'm going to refer to
these as the top down method and the
bottom up method the top-down method
means taking a bottle of pepsi and
trying to remove the color from it
without removing its flavor
and that's what i'm going to try first
but if that fails i will have to resort
to the bottom-up method which means
making cola myself from scratch i
compared the ingredients of crystal
pepsi and regular pepsi and it seems the
main difference
is that crystal pepsi does not contain
the caramel coloring that regular pepsi
does
so if we can get that caramel coloring
out of pepsi we should be left with
crystal pepsi but i have no idea how to
do any of that
so i'm gonna do some research first
[Music]
so i found a couple of people that have
tried to take the color out of pepsi and
it seems like all of them have a
relatively similar way they add
something to the pepsi
that separates the caramel from the rest
of the cola
what they use is um
they use milk whole milk and pepsi yum
let's go shopping
[Music]
i'm going to put my lab coat on because
it's time to do science all right now
that i'm a scientist
legally i don't have a phd or a
doctorate barely have a bachelor's
degree it's in film
but i have the mindset of a scientist
i've watched a few videos of people
doing this and
it always looks very gross so i'm gonna
do it
all this involves is pouring whole milk
into
pepsi the whole milk should combine with
the caramel and the pepsi and it should
sink
to the bottom then i should be able to
filter out the coagulated milk caramel
mixture and i should be left with a
clear-ish pepsi-like mixture i hope
[Music]
so the milk in here should combine with
the caramel and the pepsi and they both
should sink to the bottom but that's
gonna take
a while i'm gonna leave this here
overnight and i'm gonna try to sleep
knowing that this monstrosity
is in my living room oh my god it looks
like the world's worst lava lamp
all right it is day two so first things
first
we have our milk monster that haunted my
dreams last night
this actually worked better than i
expected it to it is
transparent at some spots so what i'm
actually gonna do is i'm going to filter
this through
a coffee filter it's not
translucent but it's no longer like
nearly as
brown as it was i'm actually going to
get another cup and i'm going to try
putting like 10 coffee filters to see if
that helps
kids pay attention in science class
because someday you could end up doing
whatever this is
oh boy this is gonna take a while isn't
it maybe i'll watch something
you you you you here come oh god
all the chunks are coming okay let's
let's add some more to this one
oh i don't want to see that it's okay
this one was more promising anyway
so even after going through many filters
this still looks disgusting and it is
certainly not
clear but a lot of the color has been
taken out of it the question that
remains
is how does it taste you know what i'm
gonna taste it
this is milk filtered crystal pepsi
for science
it just tastes like sugar water but like
with a slight hint of pepsi and also a
slight hint of spoiled milk
but i think i have a better solution
thankfully on my shopping trip yesterday
i had the foresight to get the
ingredients that i
need the main component of a cola is
what's called a 7x flavoring and that's
the selection of essential oils and
those include orange oil
lemon oil cinnamon oil nutmeg oil and
coriander oil as well as neroli oil
unfortunately i was not able to get
those exact oils so what i'm going to be
doing instead is i'm going to be taking
the
raw components and i'm going to use a
mortar and pestle to grind them together
and so i'm going to start with some
orange peel i'm going to get about 10
grams of this oh this is gonna take me a
minute isn't it
four grams of cinnamon one gram of
nutmeg
add some coriander seeds i guess that
cola is really like a cinnamon citrus
drink so i don't actually need to grind
this into a
fine powder but this should be enough so
typically to make an essential oil you
either use something called steam
distillation or you can soak it in an
oil for like a month obviously i don't
have time to do that but i found a trick
online
i'm going to be heating up a bit of this
coconut oil about five tablespoons worth
then i'm gonna add all of the
ingredients that we ground together in
the mortar and pestle as well
as about four grams of the neroli oil
then i'm just gonna let this sit over
low heat for about 30 minutes and
eventually we're going to strain off the
oil so that we're left with
a cola flavored essential oil so now
what i'm left with
is basically a bottle of pepsi
essential oils but here's where i
encounter an issue this
is oil i have to mix this with
carbonated water
oil and water don't play too well
together what i need is an emulsifier
which
will coat the oil particles in a
hydrophilic coating which means that the
oil can be
dispersed throughout the water and
therefore i can have a mixture of oil
and water so last night i actually
ordered gum arabic which is the
emulsifier that's used in pepsi for
overnight shipping but when i went
downstairs to pick up my package
it looks like someone had stolen it
someone doesn't want science to happen
and you know what i'm gonna prove them
wrong because you know what else can be
used as an emulsifier
alcohol this won't make the cola
alcoholic because a we're gonna be
cooking this a little more
and b there's gonna be so little alcohol
in this that it
isn't even worth mentioning so i'm going
to take 10 milliliters of this vodka and
mix it with three tablespoons of the oil
i made
so you can see how at the bottom of this
the oil and the
vodka are not quite mixing so what i
need to do
is to take this immersion blender and
mix these together
so i have an emulsion now and that means
i can start making pepsi
so if i were making normal cola the next
step would actually be to caramelize
some sugar but
since we don't want that caramel color
we're going to forgo
that step and instead move on to the
next step which is to combine all the
rest of the ingredients to make a cola
syrup so to make the flavoring syrup
we're going to need 600 grams of sugar
three and a half grams of citric acid
and then i just need to add in my
flavoring
and 500 milliliters of water which is
about 2.1 cups
so that's pretty much it to make the
syrup i just have to heat this over
medium heat for a little while till it's
all combined
i'm minutes from my own homemade crystal
pepsi i can feel it
okay so i apparently didn't do a good
enough job emulsifying
the essential oil with the alcohol um so
i'm gonna need to try doing that again
because this time the oil very much just
separated from the water
[Music]
the trope of the mad scientist makes
total sense
zero
[Music]
this is starting a bit
stronger it looks like will this succeed
will i go insane trying to make
something that i should never have set
out to make in the first place
okay so something magical has happened
there's a few
flecks of oil here and there but i think
the most of it is properly emulsified i
think i might be on my way to making
crystal pepsi tonight the last minutes
the moment of truth
let's make some seltzer
[Music]
two tablespoons 12 ounces
of my soda water
[Music]
it's clear it is clear i've made
some sort of beverage that is clear
but that is not pepsi also the oil is
separating again
oh my god what do i do next like look at
this
the oil and the water are clearly still
separated and so
i sit amongst the myths of my failure
telling you to not fail where i failed
and hoping
that you have more success in your
endeavors than i did in this
okay so it is nearly two in the morning
but i have just had
a breakthrough you see this bottle this
is full
of something that tastes almost but not
entirely
unlike pepsi and it's clear and there's
just a tiny bit of oil at the top
so defeated i walked over and i sat on
the couch for three hours but then
around one i decided it was probably
time to start cleaning things up
but i'd left the flavoring mixture
sitting on the stove i just left it to
cool
when i saw it though all of the oil had
kind of formed
at the top so i thought to myself why
don't i just scrape this off and i took
a little taste of the flavoring
and it had both the flavors of the sugar
the citric acid and the water as well as
the flavors of the oil
to some degree they did combine so i
took some of that flavoring compound
which still clearly had a little bit of
oil in it because there is a bit of
separation here
and i added it to seltzer water and i
poured it into this bottle and
it's not bad it tastes like a less
caramelly cola
it's not my favorite soda i'll give it
that but like after two days of trying
i'll take it i'm very happy with how
this turned out
you